whoa rise and shine Young Republicans
here take these some water you look like
you had a fun night I saw you at the
Americans for Tax Reform Party you look
like you're pacing yourself ready for a
long night but they called Kentucky so
fast so you had to have a drink for
Mitch McConnell and one of those mini
hamburgers and then West Virginia
flipped they haven't elected a
republican senator since nineteen
fifty-six you gotta drink to that so now
you're feeling pretty good and you head
across town to Union Station Big Bash
there for Republicans and it seems like
every race is going your way you're up
to five seats now flipped one more and
Republicans control the Senate and then
Fox News calls Iowa for Joni Ernst it is
time to dance your friend says hey you
sure you want that on camera and you're
like what that camera let's do this
this night is epic this party only goes
until midnight so you hit up some late
night Chinese and you're in bed by one
that's good because as mom always says
nothing good happens after polls close
in Alaska